a late night boat tragedy has taken the
lives of several people including women
and children
The Vessel with at least 30 passengers
on board most on the summer holidays
capsized in the coastal town of tanoor
in the southern state of Kerala
one family lost 11 members in the
accident
some of the survivors are in critical
condition in hospital
the incident happened late on Sunday and
with Nightfall rescue operations were a
challenge
The Vessel has been pulled ashore and
Indian coast guards and the national
disaster relief Force were engaged in
looking for those still missing and
retrieving bodies From the Muddy Waters
many are believed to be trapped inside
when the boat overturned
an inquiry has been set up to
investigate the cause of the disaster
day of mourning and compensation to the
next of kin anxious relatives gather at
the hospital
awaiting news of their loved ones
Neville Nazareth Sky News India